oh yes that's what all the raider nation
wants is a champion hey this graphic
over my shoulder here tells you the
story we now have two major sports teams
with major fan bases raider nation and
the medieval maniacs fans who love their
team but what happens when that passion
is divided some fans hope to serve both
and will go to great lengths to make
sure their allegiance never fades
there are passionate fans and then
there's this las vegas abel cervantes is
a raiders fan first but his wife is a
golden knights fan so to make peace he
cut his car in half this side it's all
golden knights but on the other side oh
he's a raider fan so naturally the other
side is full on raiders yesterday was a
good day went around had a lot of fans
loving it and
the hockey was happening
on the strip everybody's loving it he
spent thousands on a car makeover but
it's perfect now his wife is happy and
so is he he's had some raiders sit in
the driver's seat their car took a
picture with it
nelson anger abram
kylie apparel a couple players have
taken pictures with them it's not just
the paint that cuts the car in half also
the engine half gold half silver the
rims and much much more so i got the
whole silver and gold engine bay brake
calipers headlights fog lights and wheel
lights everything
one of the night raiders side is white
and the golden knight side is about a
yellow gold district in color so when
you see abel driving around las vegas
hey give him a thumbs up there might not
be a more passionate fan he spent sixty
thousand dollars on this machine to make
sure both he and his wife could share
time behind the wheel what is your
favorite color mines is the white one
the raider nation
all right raider nation hey did you
notice on the hood of the car it's the
aviators reyes de plata right on the
roof there hey if you miss it now how
about the aces